[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
get him off the bike
get that man
off of the bike
y'all know he's a senior citizen man
and that's as much citizen as you can
get that's it
okay that dude is right you know
that dude's hanging out right there on
uh
on the lord's doorstep dude
if the lord had a ring cam you would see
uh joe biden's on that thing
so don't tell me he ain't just he ain't
he ain't uh about dead
okay and y'all putting him on a bike
and you should be ashamed of yourself
his wife too
whatever her name is ronald ron
i don't know i don't know what her name
is but you don't put that you don't put
that man on a damn bike
you don't put a senior citizen like that
on a bike and if you do put them in that
little seat in the back
and let somebody tough out there drive
them around so like every now and then
there's a political thing that happens
that i gotta talk about and this week
it's biden
falling off of the bicycle dude
this is the whole thing i always said
when i was a kid
i said there should be one
uh more
uh rule on having your driver's license
you should and this has nothing to do
with the biden thing but
it kind of does in at the end of it
you have to be able to catch a ball
that's it
if someone throws you a ball and they
can underhand it but you have to be able
to catch it if you can't catch it you
can't operate a car you can't operate a
bicycle you just can't you got to stop
doing that right okay and what this does
is it weeds out the people who are gonna
[ __ ] kill people by mistake
it weeds out people that are gonna crash
in you it weeds out people that are
gonna [ __ ] drive off a cliff for by a
mistake
they're going to be operating a forklift
and spear somebody right
this is the thing after 60 there has to
be a universal test across the whole
planet and it's the throw a ball test
it's to throw me a ball test you've got
to stand there
and you've got it somebody's going to be
you know five feet away from you and
they throw your ball you get two chances
if you can't catch them all two times
that's it
you gotta walk everywhere or be a
passenger
and you can't operate heavy machinery
joe biden there's no way this
[ __ ] would pass this pass a ball
test
so he shouldn't be on a bicycle
this guy fell
harder than dodge coin joe biden fell
off a bicycle good lord
what is the secret service letting that
guy in a [ __ ] bicycle for i swear to
god you literally have a president who
shouldn't even be driving and you're
going to stick him on a bicycle he's
getting one of those motorcycles that
has three wheels on it
good lord
i mean that's when you know you're old
when you forget how to ride a bicycle
you know that's you know something you
never forget oh you live long enough you
do duncan thinks that the biden that
fell off the bike yesterday was a fake
man dude no
body double did you see his [ __ ] body
pull it up he's got a nice bob yeah
biden has nice legs he is nice don't
hate i think you're hating i was i
couldn't have been happier to watch that
guy fall off that [ __ ] body that's
how high gas prices are
he is the gift that keeps giving if
you're not a biden fan i haven't seen it
yet let's see it it's fun all right wait
you haven't seen this
holy [ __ ] i think that's him dude watch
the video yeah it's definitely there's
the video of him falling oh he looks
pretty toned it's so sad he says i'm
good wait he's already wearing he's not
wearing knee pads
i think above it is the video that's it
it's so sad should have had a knee pad i
hope it's just he didn't have any no he
goes down hard can i see what's the
wobble style
no no wobble dude got good
i'm kind of amazed that he falls down so
much because if you look at his legs
they look pretty sturdy
so he gets there oh that'll [ __ ] you up
no we didn't see it
fake oh
he couldn't stop
there's plenty of other other videos
look at that guy smiling because he got
it that guy was so happy dude trying to
do stunts and whatever he's doing it's
just
i don't like the way they parade in this
that man around he's just something's
you know he's not well
he's mentally getting older
and he just you can't do it it's not
fair i'm sure other countries look at
him
and they're like damn bro
so i just it's just time to stop you
know to me it seems sad that we keep
putting him out because he don't seem
well
and i think he's brave because he keeps
going out there but damn
get that man off at a damn bike you see
somebody fall off a bike you're happy
yeah yeah
but when they're that old it becomes
really funny like if a 20 year old guy
falls like that it's not as funny as a
79 year old guy falling like that yeah
the president the president coming to be
like hey everybody who yeah who falls
more than him because he used to be they
used to joke around about gerald ford
being clients that's right that was the
last guy that they talked about being a
klutz yeah i mean that's right he fell a
lot that was a good thing yeah he would
fall walking up the air force one stairs
that's great no you didn't know that
yeah well here he goes stupid there he
goes he's down oh my goodness he was
stopped what was that well his foot got
stuck in the little [ __ ] pedal thing
and he thought he was gonna pull he was
gonna lean his weight on his right leg
but he already put his try to get his
foot out of the pedal thing and he
already committed to go down there he
goes i'm fine you shook it up it's
hilarious he's talking to the kids now
i'm fine by the way
he got up he got up well too that's a
hard fall i think he's talking to a
youngin he's all right he does love the
youngest he does love he'll just smell
them it's a [ __ ] not moving at all so
nervous
can't get his foot out of the pedal
dude it's a [ __ ] when you're coasting
and you're not moving just like this
smitch with the helmet has to do it
because his president needs to be a
[ __ ] role model
smith the helmet now
all good you're 80.
get off the bike
not like that
get off the bike don't ever get on the
bike
promoting health promoting safety
smidge with the helmet
fell got up said he's okay
defensive now
smitch and sidney francivo that's our
president
how look i'm not politically charged
vote for whoever the [ __ ] you want i
don't care i got friends that voted for
trump close friends and i have friends
that voted for biden close friends
i don't give a [ __ ] i buy yeezys even
though kanye's a lunatic
i i i don't care i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't do the thing well i i buy new
balance because i had a new balance why
people tried to pressure [ __ ] steph
curry to not
work with him because they voted for
trump and he's not spoken about trump i
don't give a [ __ ] dude if the shoe's
nice the kid's getting it
but the president has to be able to
catch a ball
or he's going to lay off the bikes you
know and it's fine but it's like dude
this guy can't catch a break poor guy
you know
poor guy fell hard what if somebody
walked up and put your granddaddy on a
bike right now
what would you tell him
get him off the bike that's what you'd
tell him that'd be so funny to be like
the pr people on that and be like we're
gonna get you you're gonna be riding a
bike everybody's saying you're not spry
right here we go i'm surprised honestly
he didn't die my grandma my great
grandma we used to call her super
grandma we would laugh so hard i don't
know why we called her super grandma but
we used to walk in and [ __ ] make her
put her arms up like this she was flying
never saw her bottom half because she
always had a blanket over it and we'd be
like do super grandma and she put her
arms like that we'd fall so hard and
then one day she fell down the stairs
broke her hip and died that's a death
sentence if you're [ __ ] 80 you fall
down you break your hip that's a death
sentence dude i have no idea why but if
you break your hip you die that's what
happens but if you're 100 you'll break a
hit hip instant death
joe biden's 80 can't believe he didn't
break [ __ ] maybe he didn't trying to
cover it up i'm not a conspiracy
theorist but you know i still think he's
a hologram honestly on his bicycle look
at this this is from
at this point i think what happens is he
takes his left foot off as you can see
he thinks his right foot is out of the
saddle clearly it's not he goes to step
down why is it this is a from first of
all this is from it says president joe
biden falls off his bike is the first
youtube video i clicked it's from boxing
now
pick a lane
also why is boxing why is boxing now
commenting on joe right on his joe biden
on joe riding on his bike joe biden on
his bike joe biden riding on his bike
joe ryan on his bike and uh also why is
there commentary on it dude i hate when
you can't get the [ __ ] video dude you
just want to see joe biden fall down and
some guy's like and that's where he did
it i think it's because now now let's
sit now here we are at the round table
why did you it's like dude
pulling him to the ground
obviously pretty scary for someone that
age to fall like that but
obviously he's he's up he's talking to
people by the way he's walking to a
little girl there in the crowd and
things seem to be going and so fine
after that
the white house chimed in their press
secretary said that he was i mean this
is not it's boxing now you know not news
we talked to the white house the white
house chimed in and said that it's not a
big issue it's going to be fine now back
to talking about evander holyfield there
were a few more comedians that reacted
on social media like joe rogan posted
this on instagram this meme of him uh
like interviewing biden after the fall
and that has 1.3 million likes mark
norman tweeted gas prices are so high
biden's on the huffy jeff ross quote
tweeted the new york times post
explaining what happened about president
biden falling off his bike saturday
while trying to dismount in front of a
small crowd of reporters and he said
once again caving to the right
jessica kirsten said did the president
fall off his bike today and then mike
cannon also tweeted guys seriously stop
by and falling off that bike could have
resulted in a lot of us laughing to
death so maybe be sensitive you [ __ ]
those are all the reactions so far we'll
make a part two if any more come out
make sure you subscribe to joke world
right now to stay in the loop combi
newswise for everything you need to know
happening in the comedy world and follow
us on instagram we'll send you some of
these free joke world stickers if you dm
us your name and address
[Music]
you